bonjour avez vous confiance en vous moi
je suis justement en train de la
travailler et j'avance bien
et oui la confiance à ce travail ça se
construit petit à petit et tout au long
de votre vie aujourd'hui chers étudiants
vous êtes un moment de votre vie où il
ya peut-être plein d'opportunités ou
plein de réflexions plein de certitudes
ou plein de doutes
certaines choses vous semble possible et
d'autres beaucoup moins
et vous verrez dix ans plus tard ce sera
toujours le cas alors en travaillant
votre confiance
elle va vous permettre d'aller plus loin
plus sereinement pour atteindre vos
rêves ou changer de voie et en tout cas
pour faire ce pour quoi vous êtes fait
pour vous donner un exemple aujourd'hui
j'ai un master en marketing et je
travaille dans un environnement
multiculturel
je parle donc anglais toute la journée
eh ben je peux vous dire qu'au début
c'était vraiment pas gagné moi j'aurais
dû redoubler mon cp selon la prof de
l'airé la maîtresse de l'école par bon
je n'aurais jamais dû faire l'iut
d'annecy beaucoup trop sélectif selon la
prof principal de terminale alors faire
une licence en anglais voulait vraiment
que je vous en parle
oui mais voilà moi je voulais faire
limited and see alors j'ai envoyé ma
candidature et j'ai fait en sorte de les
convaincre durant l'entretien
quant à l'anglais il ya toujours des
solutions
je reconnais que les concours d'entrée
pour aller dans des pays anglophones
vu mon niveau d'anglais salle être
compliqué mais j'ai trouvé la solution
la norvège c'était le seul pays où il
n'y avait pas de concours d'entrée bah
oui il ya dix ans en arrière la norvège
a semblé loin et froid personne ne
voulait y aller donc bien sûr au début
j'ai galéré avec mon niveau d'anglais
mais au bout d'un ou deux mois ça avait
déjà beaucoup mieux et puis entre nous
toutes les occasions sont bonnes pour
pratiquer la langue les soirées
étudiantes savent bien
donc ce que je vais vous dire c'est que
ça se fait et que ça se travaille
quand on n'a pas voulu me faire passer
par la porte et bien je suis rentré par
la fenêtre les ma première ressource
pour y arriver
ça a été mon instinct j'ai toujours eu
la volonté profonde de l'écouter parfois
ce n'était qu'un murmure mais il me
disait tout le temps c'est ce que tu
aimes et même quand c'était qu'un
murmure ça m'a donné l'impulsion pour
construire mes projets alors voilà les
trois choses qui me sont personnellement
essentiel pour accroître ma confiance en
moi
du positif du courage et de
l'inspiration et voilà quelques astuces
pour les développer le positif
et oui ça se travaille j'utilise une
méthode très simple mais terriblement
efficace qui est de noter tous les soirs
trois choses que j'ai aimé dans ma
journée et même quand j'ai passé une
très mauvaise journée
ça peut être l'odeur du café le matin
qui m'a plu aux une chanson à la radio
qui m'a donné envie de danser ou j'ai
tout simplement adoré aller me coucher
parce que cette journée enfin terminé et
pourquoi ça marche parce que des études
montrent que 90 % de nos pensées sont
les mêmes chaque jour et que la plupart
d'entre elles sont négatives
ce qui veut dire que neuf sur dix de nos
pensées en plus d'être récurrente pour
la plupart sont négatives en identifiant
simplement trois choses positives par
jour ont fini par changer de perspective
sur sa propre vie plus on crée de
l'espace pour le positif et plus on
apprend à savourer les petites choses à
son souvenir est à l'aise en créant non
des études montrent qu'au bout d'une
semaine de pratique seulement il ya déjà
des effets notables sur le bonheur et
qui s'amplifie avec le temps ça vaut le
coup d'essayer non
je vous conseille de vous engager à le
faire avec avec quelqu'un ça aide à le
faire quotidiennement 2 le courage même
combat ça se pratique et pour moi une
des méthodes qui marche le mieux est de
faire une fois par jour quelque chose
que je n'ai encore jamais fait et là
encore ça peut être des toutes petites
choses comme par exemple changer
d'itinéraire quand je vais au travail ou
faire mes courses dans un supermarché
différents ou tout simplement ici une
nouvelle recette de cocktail
peu importe ce qui est important c'est
de le faire régulièrement
et là encore pourquoi ça marche parce
qu'en tant qu'être humain on a la
capacité d'accepter de très grands
changements et d'être flexible cependant
c'est souvent notre peur qui parlent en
premier ce sentiment de peur il est
désagréable mais une dure pas longtemps
car même si la nouveauté nous effraie
elle emmène aussi en nous une sensation
de curiosité et d'intrigués cet exercice
nous fait sortir de notre zone de
confort et prendre confiance en nous il
transforme nos peurs en impulsions
utiliser nos peurs comme moteur cela
nous permettra de mieux affronter les
futures obstacles
3 l'inspiration si j'avais écouté toutes
les personnes qui me limitais
aujourd'hui je ne serais pas là mais on
a aussi tous autour de nous quelqu'un
qui nous inspire et j'ai eu durant mon
parcours universitaire particulièrement
à l'iae des profs super inspirant qui
m'ont poussé motiver et donner envie
d'avancer alors entourez vous de ces
personnes qui vous inspire laissez les
vous embarquer et écouter leurs conseils
ils sont précieux
parce que l'inspiration c'est
l'étincelle qui va vous permettre de
construire votre projet votre rêve ou
votre idée alors il y aura peut-être pas
quinze mille personnes qui vous inspire
mais des fois il suffit d'une personne
ou même d'une phrase pour nous donner la
plains le pour pardon excusez moi pour
me donner l'impulsion dont on a besoin
alors pour augmenter sa confiance en soi
il faut du positif du courage et de
l'inspiration
certains d'entre vous ont peut être déjà
essayé d'atteindre leurs projets ou
leurs rêves
peut-être que ça n'a pas marché et
peut-être que vous n'avez plus confiance
et bien persévérer
aussi longtemps qu'il le faudra est ce
que vous savez combien de fois tombe un
enfant avant d'apprendre à marcher
environ 2400 x est ce que vous savez
pourquoi après tout ces chutes
il finit quand même par apprendre à
marcher parce que ses parents n'ont
aucun doute sur sa capacité à marcher
alors sur ce point soyez vos propres
parents ayez confiance en vous et
dépasser vos limites
je vous dis pas que c'est facile je vous
dis que ça vaut le coup car la vraie
question au fond ce n'est pas ce que
vous pouvez faire mais ce que vous
voulez faire et c'est à cette question
que j'aimerais que vous réfléchissiez
qu'est ce que vous voulez vraiment
qu'est ce qui vous anime
quand on fait taire toutes vos peurs
toutes vos voix limite entre qu'est ce
qui reste
alors maintenant chers étudiants c'est à
vous quel est votre rêve
et quel est le prochain pas aussi petit
soit-il qui vous rapprochera de lui
merci de votre écoute
[Applaudissements]